[Music]
what is framework and why do we need it
wherever you go people will ask you have
you developed any framework but what is
the need of a framework so obviously is
that framework makes creation and
maintenance or prescript
easy okay absolutely correct putting a
standards absolutely correct it contains
it has a bunch of everything we need so
that libraries reporting everything okay
so first of all why is our framework is
not a hard-and-fast rules which you need
to follow dream up but just a standard
or some you know guidelines which you
follow you make are absolutely correct
set of guidelines to make it usable
portable scalable
maintainable citroen so actually this is
weird
fringo comes on a picture but whatever
the scripts you are writing you don't
need to write it again and again so it
will make it reusable it will make it
portable that you write it on Windows
you can work on any doubles grading
system with Nick is cable so Matt you
write it or you know if you create it
for for this version and of course if
there is a new version comes in there is
no impact on your framework and it is
maintainable so you can easily maintain
it whenever there is a change required
you can go and make the change and
that's it okay so this is a best part
these are the things these are the few
important points or two framework let's
see what it says why why do you need a
framework for medium to large automation
projects when there are large and
complex application when there is a need
of compatibility across browsers and
platforms in case there is a giant
development with shorter or D cycle when
there is a need for multiple
technologies and dynamic Acronis
asynchronous application in case of
slaughter testing cycles against growing
sued beezly's so of course you know you
understand that that when we have
automation test cases it to always grow
it will always keep on increasing like a
decoration pack but aggression pack
keeps on increasing with a number of
test cases correct in the same way our
automation pack will always be increased
so in back here we have to maintain them
and that's a framework comes over into
the picture
target should be able to create
automation test suit once and you stable
forever when the automation projects
don't last more than a few releases
confirmation projects should work across
browsers and platforms application
supports ok so you say today a clamp or
sorry a chrome it will run in chrome if
you say a transfer it will run internet
explorer wherever you want to run it it
will run reusable and easy to maintain
trying to adapt to changes very quickly
like we discuss about page black model
if we there is any change happen we
can't make the change very easily us
very quickly support execution end
autopilot mode with minimum human
support that means if you schedule a
demo in the night at 3:00 a.m. it will
execute and share the result instead of
human intervention supports final
execution of virtual machines means an
unplowed so if you want you can run
whose execution annually on multiple
machines frameworks are helpful as they
enable structure automation so
everything your complete project is
structure as will be easy for you to
work that enable collaborative
development so that you know collaborate
development piece you may be developing
the utility one person developing the
test cases one person is developing one
person is you know creating the page
classes so that's how you are dividing
the things and at the last you combine
all of them and are improve the
usability and maintainability provide
affecting test results reporting in
circles in this change we are getting
the test result reporting so that's what
we will be going to use a good framework
helps improve quality and speed of
generating automation test scripts so if
you have a good framework you can create
your test scripts very easily very very
easily and in this short span of time
we do have multiple type of frame box to
be precise these are not only for we
have more type of frame access well but
people are mostly aware of T type of
frameworks only you know if you go than
the industry ninety to ninety nine
percent of the people are aware of T's
for framework types in T and those are
modular driven framework data driven
framework keyword driven framework in
hybrid driven framework these are the
four type of frameworks
what we have listed in this slide every
framework has its own way or has its own
functionality as its own architecture I
would say and it's up to us that which
one we are going to work on it's up to
us
on deciding that which one is beneficial
for our project so we'll be discussing
about each framework one by one okay a
person will not be developing all the
frameworks there but we'll be discussing
about it one by one here we go
so what is modular automation framework
it is the most basic thing of what an
automation framework provides business
functionality abstraction as each
business function idea module is handled
independently it scripts are mapped to
modules and to in this cases call these
modules to integrate scripts so what
will happen here is we have created one
script which is going to do the sign-in
as well as going to front office as well
as going to more office as well as to
the back office etc the script 2 is
going to more back office utility script
2 is going to back up a security billing
sure every script is not reusing things
or I would say is repeatedly repeating
things again and again the same things
again and again which is not good
actually
like we write the scripts ok we write
the script if we use some external
module as well and HoloNet we will call
it as modular automation framework ok we
are we have creating modules that this
is for login this is for silent and this
is for that and that so to be precise I
have never seen people using modular
automation field never in my career okay
and you know while giving my corporate
trainings as well I have never seen
people using multiple tools available
because it's not new use actually it it
loans to it will only increase increase
the complexity of the framework that's
it what are the advantage easy and
maintenance because really fast
efficient script creation when modular
automation frameworks is used with
data-driven framework effectiveness
improves of course when you exam there
is a common external source
data-driven means you are driving the
data from some external source means you
are using the test data from an excel
sheet from a database from a property
file from a
pad or from any external file that's
what we call it as data-driven testing
so in this it says that the benefits are
it is easy to maintain faster test
script creation time better scalability
but too imprecise when we have a good
automation claim of develop you will see
that in the future slides when we have a
good script you know framework develop
you can create a script in a few minutes
in a few minutes you can create your
scripts and that's why I'm not going you
know inside this module automation
framework in detail but yes if I talk
about rated run framework it used a lot
earlier it used a lot earlier now people
are using this framework with the page
object model a lot so earlier it was
used a lot now people are using it with
pages at modal a lot ok so I will not
say that the usage is discrete it is
started decreasing but the page reject
model comes into the picture and the
usage of rated driven increased again so
this go in our data driven framework so
from my perspective from explains that
within the way we used to use today that
when we used to create a little flavor
through thesis then the project length
is or project duration I would say
project duration is less than 3 to 6
months
we try to double updated run framework
why because this data driven framework
we can develop it and or the queries and
then we can start using it and that's
why it becomes very very easy for us to
create here driven framework where every
project and that's what of course we
will be going to see that in our in
tomorrow session that creating later
data driven framework ourself in that
two to three hours and driving data from
an external source so it can be MS
section it can be CSV it can we release
it can be XML which can be Jason you can
we are driving the data from it excels
with sheet input expected results are
read from an external source data is
then passed with the test scripts for
execution actual results will sell
expected results from external source
can be verified so we verify the data
which is coming from the excel sheet
whether they are correct or not
and according we'll mark that particular
test is s pass or fail so actually just
only the difference is we will be
driving data from an external source and
depths were data driven free voltage
benefits improved coverage and quality
focus on data before creation of this
slips when they determine framework is
used along with modular keyword run
frameworks effectiveness increases
suppose if I say with a baton frame this
is what the industry uses today so let's
first understand you would driven and
then you will go to 501 and we'll see
combining data and he would run how it
is actually helps so keyword driven
framework is an application independent
framework uses data tables and keyword
poor actions in this framework this data
in key words on is stored in an external
so when I see test did I of course you
understand by this data of course the
suggested or normal your CV is an extra
file but when I say keywords what I mean
to say here you capture the screenshot
how do you capture it you write to line
of code for capturing a screenshot but
we will create a keyword that is called
as take screenshot or we will say it
will give it a new name to it capture
screen or wherever you will say capture
screenshot with parameter like suppose
filename we capture the screenshot and
you know it will save it with the
filename what you mention it in this is
one keyword for you now wherever you
need to use it you will just say instead
of mentioning those two line of food you
will say takes a screenshot in the same
way if you have um let's say mouse over
so as a mouse over
element / element flick 11 and up then
if you want to click will say click X
bar that will create a keyword for
everything what you do inside your
scripts you create a keyword for that
will you know will create QT words
tomorrow in the class and I'll show that
to you that how we can create fusion how
we can use them Israel so we'll create
keyboards so that we don't need to write
those a long line of foods you can
simply use them and that's what is
keyword driven framework we put these
keywords in a exercise excel sheet or
any external source and we create our
test cases and how do we create our test
cases in that case if we have those keys
you're becoming to that little computer
let me complete the habit ravenous well
then I'll form and tell you the
difference between these two this is
understand this the keyword-driven what
I am going to create it so we have
created some keys and here you see this
is one this is step what are the test
steps open this is mighty navigate click
verify these are my keys what are me to
do the need suppose they need some
parameters
open no parameter required navigate
click on
you
you
we ratify
that this is your test case his tooth
and this is how you will keep on writing
your test cases inside the next sheet
and you don't need to open your scripts
their scripts you don't need to move
their you don't need to book your script
you don't need to go to your cool etc
because you have created your keys you
have created in your actions and when
what will happen when you will execute
your framework it will come to the first
road will pick whatever the step is that
will go and execute it it will pick the
second step then the third step then
looping the whole step and done it will
mark it as pass/fail or whatever then
stick in this case it will pick all the
steps and market then tar then pour the
fifth and that's how your test case will
be written in evil driven framework
mainly in the excel sheet
so in keyword run framework you create
keys in modular driven we don't create
since okay we create modules modules
needs login a one login is one module
registration is another module forward
password is another module those modules
that's what we create in motor-driven
but we'll come to that value so that's
what we do in he were to run framework
you were driven framework is so you know
we created only if the project will be
going about greater than six months and
it will take somewhere on five to seven
days to create it completely and this
people uses it this is what I can say so
here we are saying keyword and actions
here we are saying the test data it will
execute the driver script which will
create a dessert for you and done this
is the user entry one hierarchy what is
mentioned here yes it this is how it
works I'm complete launch what about you
see buddy I completely go in family idea
advantage of people people guess I don't
need an expertise in tester tools such
as selenium Prakriti scripts saying that
tester do not need to have an expertise
because there is not required you just
need to open an excel sheet and just
need to mention the keys and done and
here you also create an index actually
where you mention that which key does
what to open key does this navigate key
does this you create an index and where
it mention this and whenever there is a
new join new you know join e comes in or
there is a manual tester comes in or you
know a non-technical guy comes in we
tell him that this means this this means
this and whenever you need to create a
space come to sheet 1 stay here too
and mention all your keys and done
so what you need to tell them you need
to tell them the indexing the keys how
to find locators he does not need to
learn selenium it does not need to learn
these IDs he does not need to learn to
stingy he does not need to learn any
bill tool any logging tool anything it's
a benefit for effective keyword driven
framework develop an informed plan to
create it
he was reduce complexity so in order to
decide on the keys names and order
decide about functionality will they do
in order to decide how we will be going
to handle it if there is any error comes
that's why it takes around 5 to 7 days
to created usually a mix of different
frameworks is used to improve the
overall benefit of automation frameworks
of course it is always suggested it mix
two frameworks team works together so
that you can take a benefit of
automation framework hybrid driven
hybrid as the name suggests it is a
combination of any two frameworks if we
combine two framework that's what we
call it as hybrid driven framework it
integrates the advantage of all other
frameworks so you will combine any two
frameworks be famous and that's what if
flexible and does not bind with the
phrase frameworks it is not bind with a
fixed framework you can combine again
both frameworks and take a benefit off
each framework you can improve
effectiveness by deciding the best
combination of framework based on the
context of automation why overdoing and
using additional framework and
necessarily okay so you can decide
whether you want you state a tree one
with modular driven or data driven with
keyword driven which one is going to
benefit you and you know if you see that
there are is always a limitation with
data driven there is a limitation with
keyword driven so the hammer driven you
can remove those limitations by
combining the benefits of multiple
frameworks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here